Web components enable you
to build great websites
through they use of
reusable components.
But what does it take to
build a web component?
My name is Ejii,
and today I'm going
to give you an overview
of HTML imports.
If you have worked
with UI libraries
like jQuery UI or
bootstrap, you know
that they require multiple tags
for loading all of the required
resources, such as scripts,
stylesheets, or web fonts.
Wouldn't it be nice
if you could load them
as a component with a
single tag because they
provide a single
set of features?
HTML imports allow you to
import an HTML file that
includes those required
resources in line,
or as a script tag or
link tag, in one place.
At the time of this
recording, HTML imports
have landed in Chrome and Opera.
Firefox supports it in
Nightly behind a flag.
But support for web
components is changing weekly,
so be sure to check
chromestatus.com
for an up to date
browser support table.
To detect the availability
of HTML imports,
check if link tag has
an imports property.
For unsupported browsers,
you can use platform.js,
a collection of web
components polyfills
made available as
polymer library.
This will automatically detect
the availability of the HTML
imports and populate
if necessary.
Using HTML imports is simple.
Just add link tag with rel
equals import to the HTML.
Instead linked HTML, you can add
any HTML markups as you wish,
including ones that load,
additional resources
such as scripts, links,
styles, and so on.
You don't need doc type HTML
head or body on imported HTML.
HTML markups will be parsed
and executed on load.
You may wonder how
browsers manage
loading multiple resources
using HTML imports.
HTML imports behave just like
defer attribute on script tag.
On loading HTML
following script tags,
we'll wait for all the
scripts in the imported HTML
to be loaded and executed.
This is a visualization
of how it works.
First, start loading index HTML.
As soon as the browser
finds the import,
it starts parsing imported HTML.
Meanwhile, parsing index
HTML continues to move on
but blocked on the
next script tag,
because the browser waits for
all script tags inside imported
HTML to be loaded and executed.
script1.js will be loaded and
executed, then script2.js.
Now the control comes
back to index HTML.
Load and execute script3.js.
Note that if you add async
attribute to HTML import,
it won't wait for the imported
HTML to be loaded and executed.
The reason async
is not default is
for ease of use for developers.
If you care about performance,
please bear in mind
that there's always an option
to use async attribute.
One important thing you should
keep in mind when using HTML
imports is that you basically
cannot import files from
outside of your origin.
If you wish to import
resources from other origins,
the server needs to
support CORS, Cross Origin
Resource Sharing.
To learn more about CORS, please
take out HTML5 Rocks article,
"Using CORS."
HTML imports execute scripts,
load styles and fonts right
when imported HTML is loaded.
But sometimes you want to access
those resources and objects
using JavaScript.
Actually, the window object
and the document object
in an imported document are
identical to the main document.
So how do we access
resources inside import HTML
from index HTML?
And how do we access
resources inside index HTML
from import HTML?
In order to access
the document object
of imported HTML from
the main document,
use import property
of the link element.
Note that you can use
onload event to make sure
that that content is already
loaded before accessing
its content, just
like other link text.
In order to access the document
object or the main HTML
from the imported document, you
can use document currentScript
ownerDocument.
If you are using
platform.js, you
need to insert an underscore
before currentScript
due to polyfill restrictions.
If you are already familiar
with web components
and actively using
a lot of components,
your HTML could look
something like this.
Wow, so many imports.
This doesn't look the best.
Loading many resources mean
that there are same or even more
network connections
when loading the page.
There are a couple of
things to note here.
Solving dependency on web
components is kind of tricky.
It can import same resources
multiple times, like this.
But don't worry, HTML
imports take care of it.
Documents from same URL will
be fetched and processed
only once.
If you care about
performance, you
will want to reduce the number
of connections to the server.
There's a library called
Vulcanize to solve the problem.
Vulcanize recursively
pulls in all your imports,
flattens their
dependencies, and spits out
something that can potentially
reduce the number of network
requests your app makes.
Now let me show you
how HTML import works
by extending the example code
we used in the previous videos.
I'm not going to explain
how templates, Shadow
DOM, and custom elements work.
But if you're curious
and haven't watched
the previous videos,
please do so.
One of the benefits of
using web components
is that you can isolate
and reuse components.
HTML imports help that
by moving components code
to a separate file.
In this case, x-component
HTML, which uses template,
custom elements, and Shadow DOM.
This file will be loaded
autonomously when imported.
Once you have a separate
HTML file that builds a web
component, you can simply
import it by using HTML imports,
and the result will
look the same as before.
So this is HTML imports.
To learn more
about HTML imports,
be sure to read the
HTML5 Rocks article
written by Eric Bidelman.
Thank you for watching.